are you feeling feeling limber you
feeling ready good we can I do this okay
all right we are here you want to do the
confident pose first yes for two minutes
it's gonna be a little bit of a boring
interview of it after the two minutes
he's gonna be awesome it's gonna be
great I am here with Jeremy cipher and
Kristin Bauer and we just got done with
Real Time with Bill Maher you were
fantastic in my opinion Kristen went
away in on this yeah I was in the
greenroom and I was so excited to hear
you say I don't think a tomato and a
fish have ever made that was it was a
very good point it's so cool that
everybody from every HBO show goes to
all the other HBO shows just for moral
support
oh my god well also it's very selfish I
just love HBO and I love HBO shows so
finally I got on one and I get to go to
places like you know we met because I
saw the sizzle reel online and this is a
passion of mine and something I follow
and I wrote Jeremy and Josh the producer
of fan level really yeah what do you
support us on Kickstarter yeah yeah and
then Josh wrote me back and said I just
signed it Kristin Bauer and he wrote
back and said are you Pam I was like oh
well yes my confident was all right here
yeah he called me and he said Pam a
vampire on True Blood is helping us on
Kickstarter and at the time I don't have
HBO but I didn't know and so I had to
get up or TV right I don't yeah I
haven't had a TV for like 15 years I
have the Internet's right right the
gateways don't have to miss your friends
HBO Go password not that I would
recommend doing that I know everyone use
my friends HP okay
whatever but I love this movie yeah you
can say I'm extremely passionate about
this movie it's it's a beautiful movie
it's entertaining it's informative and
this guy you probably couldn't have made
this movie without the most adorable
children in the world and my beautiful
wife and you're holding it all together
yeah but it's about a family trying to
navigate this world and look at what and
how they're raising their children and
of course you care about your children
and none of us know about GMOs and so
that's it's an amazing good look at a
complicated subject
you were telling bill that one of the
things that made you decide to do this
film was the farmers protests in Haiti
how much of it was that and how much of
it was just personal you know having
kids and you know them to watch what
they eat and and being responsible for
that yeah it's it started with Haiti and
when I got back from Haiti it suddenly
became very personal because there was
the ice cream truck that parked in front
of our house every night and then Mucky
yeah I thought it was lucky at first the
beautiful song is I read their bedtime
stories and then they say ice cream and
it's all genetically modified and filled
with chemicals and dyes and and yeah it
felt like inescapable and I became upset
as a parent because they will take
whatever we give them they don't know we
have to look out for them and be
responsible for them I am the same way
yeah you're like a young child who
doesn't know in many ways yes I will
look out for you too
what do you eat like how do you how do
you control what's what's gone in your
body
GMO versus non GMO
I mean we eat predominantly organic food
because organic by its very definition
is non-gmo but it's also no toxic
pesticides and herbicides and synthetic
fertilizers so it's it it's more a part
of what I perceive as a system of
nurture and nurturing the earth and
genetically modified organisms and what
they represent is modern agribusiness
and Agri sons and that is a system at
the base and coralie is a system of
exploitation rather than nurture
Monsanto has altered this much of this
huge thing called life and they get to
own the entire thing and I kind of feel
like I'm not a religious person but I
think really really the whole thing
that's initiated does my hair and now
takes responsibility for the whole thing
which I did her hair tonight I thought
this is where this is going my last
question is what after you start this
conversation what's gonna be we're gonna
get him drunk later yeah yeah tonight
I'm gonna drink a little bit rest a
little bit I don't know I haven't my
mind hasn't been freed yet until right
about now with these premieres to think
about I mean just two weeks ago I had a
beard like this big and my hair was done
here and I was like coming out of a cave
from this film just I didn't know what
was going on in the world I shaved it
and now it's starting to grow back
already but so I don't know well welcome
back to the land of the living thank you
best of luck with the premiere and it's
night and good luck with getting this
conversation started and keeping it
going thank you and now Jeremy back to
the conference Dennis yes back to the
company
then I get ham I didn't do a real good
you know because it's supposed to be the
dog Lister I went oh serious you know
names for real that one if I can do what
how do you do pinion it's the head huh
dad can we get out of the way I'm so
let's got an air breath that air
biologies that left eyebrow
how did I get the right one but it was
kind of matching yeah that's fine I feel
like I wanna suck some let's do it wait
no no no guys guys yeah I told you